how to make products your customers will
like so is doing a Google+ hangout with
one of my authors Dave kerlun and I got
a great question I wanted to make a
video response to so the question came
in from Canario Games who wrote in to
say what do you need to make products
that your target audience would like
this is a great question and one that a
lot of entrepreneurs face when thinking
hey I need what products do I make I
gotta make something that I'm excited
about that I know will help my customers
so think about it one of the most
important rules in business is if you
want to make money you have to provide
value to your customers right that's
what people are paying you you want to
make a lot of money you need to provide
a lot of value to your customers and a
lot of times that value comes by solving
a pain solving a problem if you solve
somebody's problem they'll pay you more
for the more important the problem that
is the more they're gonna pay you for it
so there's two ways to do it one is you
are your customer right you're making it
because you have a problem and you
created this product to solve the
problem for you and you know it works
for you you recommend it it works you
love it so other people will as well a
great example is Leon Leon wood beam who
started l.l.bean he was a hunter and
when he went hunting he was frustrated
that his feet always got what because
his shoes sucked because the shoes
weren't meant for hunting so he made his
own hunting shoe and how do you know
wood work because it worked for him
because he was a hunter because he was
his own target audience and then he sold
to other hunters and they loved it so
that's how he knew that's how you can
know right are you your own customer or
not the second way is if you're not your
own customer hanging around your
customers a lot understanding their
problem understanding their needs being
able to talk to them speak to them see
what they're going through the biggest
challenges they're facing in their
companies right now right talk to those
people really get to know them and
they'll tell you they may not tell you
the solution you have to come up with
that but they'll tell you their problems
they'll tell you their pain and if
somebody is telling you a big pain
there's an opportunity to potentially
solve it
so let me give you two examples from my
own experience okay
I sell the entrepreneurs and I sell two
brands when it's telling entrepreneurs
it may be content like this video it may
be the Zuka guys I'm selling it may be a
workshop whatever it is I can understand
entrepreneurs I know what content to
create because I'm an entrepreneur right
this is the stuff I wish I had I had to
struggle through this crap I've started
my own business and failing and wanting
to quit and then eventually building it
up and turn it around and being acquired
and all of that stuff so I'll share my
lessons I know what I would have wanted
and I wish this stuff was there for me
when I was getting started so I am my
own audience the second part is I sell
the brands now I'm not I'm not a brand
right I'm not a huge company I'm not
Microsoft I'm not Dell I'm not Google
but I sell to those guys but I can speak
their language I got close to them
we have lunches and dinners and coffees
and sessions together right I help them
plan and so I know the problems that
they're going through by getting close
to them if you are not your target
customer and you're not close to your
target customer then how you're going to
find their major problem and find a
product that will help solve it so
that's my advice the best one is if you
are your own customer and you love it
because other people you know there are
other people out there who are just like
you who want it too but if you can't if
you're not your customer then hanging
around your customers and get really
close to them believe that's my advice I
love to hear how you guys started your
business how you found your first
customer if you are your customer or if
you're finding ways to get close to your
customers please leave it in the
comments below so other people can
benefit from it as well be inspired by
your story you guys like this video
thumbs up below click on my face
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon